by way of film we traveled to Munich and
Kirk Douglas who will present the film
editing award now I understand that this
year setting has a piece of film all
around the globe well as far as I am
concerned that's accurate enough because
a particular piece of film has the glory
has brought me here to Munich and that's
quite a few reels away from Hollywood in
vine but by the same means film I'm glad
to be with you tonight to honor the film
editors those men and women who do such
a fantastic job of putting little pieces
of film together and out comes a motion
picture if you think that's easy just
try it sometime so the nominees for the
best achievement in film editing this
year are Jean fuji arrow and paul
Weatherwax for around the world in 80
days Meryl G white for the brave one
William Hornbeck Philip W Anderson and
Fred Bohannon for giant Albert aksed for
somebody up there likes me and and
Balkans for the ten commandments and now
let's open the envelope and see this
year's winner the winner were around the
world in 80 days quinoa green arrow and
all wet away
I would like to thank Mike Todd Kevin
McClory and all the boys that made this
possible I thank
I wanted a fellas he cut a picture I was
in some not terrific